Elizabeth Hurley is speaking out in
honor of Steve Bank her ex and a father
of her child following the news of his
death being a film producer and
philanthropist died by suicide on Monday
leaping off of a building in Century
City California
according to reports he was 55 years old
on Tuesday morning Curley who shares 18
year old son Damien with Bing took to
social media to share a few snaps with
her ex she captioned the post quote I'm
saddened beyond belief that Steve is no
longer with us our time together was
very happy and although there were some
tough times the memories of a sweet kind
man are what matter
Hurley added that the two had become
close again in the last year and she
last spoke to being on her son's
birthday in April quote this is
devastating news early Sunday Mian also
shared his grief on social media posting
this pic of a sunset thinking fans in
the caption for reaching out quote this
is a very strange and confusing time and
I'm immensely grateful to be surrounded
by my phenomenal family and friends
according to TMZ being reportedly jumped
from the 27th floor of a luxury
apartment tower where he lived on Monday
a rep for the LAPD told ET they are
still investigating being the founder of
shangri-la entertainment was best known
for financing films like 2004's
Polar Express
and 2007's Beowulf I claimed after my
battle with five near the dragon of the
northern moors nearly cost me my life
being inherited six hundred million
dollars from his grandfather Leo s ping
when he was 18 years old and dropped out
of college to focus on establishing a
career in Hollywood one of the first
films he served on as a producer was the
Sylvester Stallone thriller Get Carter
in 2000 Bing also wrote several
screenplays including missing in action
as well as the 2003 comedy kangaroo jack
come on Manny this one picture for the
Brooklyn crew all right just one oh
let's make this quick but in addition to
investing in film projects Bing was also
a large contributor in progressive
political causes and philanthropic
organizations according to The Giving
Pledge Bing had committed to giving a
majority of his assets to charitable
organizations over the course of his
lifetime
[Music]